joining us now exclusively on the phone
is the president of the united states mr
president
thank you for taking time uh for being
with us tonight
well thank you sean very much it's an
honor i appreciate you being here
you really have not had an opportunity
to
react and respond to the the mueller
report
the ag's letter that that summarized the
report
that exonerated you no collusion after
all these years as you have been
claiming
uh he left the decision as it relates to
obstruction to the attorney general and
deputy attorney general
they quickly said no that does not rise
to that level and i wanted to get your
reaction
well we're very happy about it it's gone
on for a long
time almost since the beginning of my
term and you know if you look at it
we've done so much despite that but it
was a cloud
it was a cloud that most people didn't
believe fortunately they spent
more than 30 million dollars hundreds of
of
interviews of people in some cases very
innocent people that were put through
the ringer millions of
document pages millions and millions of
document pages and after that there was
no collusion there was no
obstruction uh it was such a ridiculous
thing that happened on the other hand
you know you look at
how did this start how did it start you
had dirty cops you had people that are
bad fbi
folks i know so many they're incredible
people but at the top
they were not clean to put it mildly
and what they did to our country was a
terrible terrible thing
mr president we've talked a lot on this
program about the fisa abuse scandal and
this is what we know
that in august of 2016 we know bruce orr
warned everybody at the doj and the fbi
that christopher steele hated you that
hillary clinton paid for the dossier
that it was not verified but still in
october
and then three renewal application
warrants approved
they were we're told by the grassley
graham memo the bulk of
information came from that phony dossier
even andrew mccabe said
no dossier no fisa warrant um
there were russian lies disseminated to
the american people before the election
but it also violated the rights of
carter page and
gave a backdoor into your campaign for
spying which
i know the media made fun of at the time
when you said it happened
well when i said there could be somebody
spying on my campaign
a lot of things happened it was like it
went wild out there they couldn't
believe that i could say such a thing
and
as it turned out that was small potatoes
compared to what went on
uh when you look at what happened and
when it happened and the money that was
spent
the millions and millions on the phony
dossier
and then they used the dossier to start
things and there was no truth whatsoever
was a fraud
and paid for by hillary clinton and paid
for by the democrats in the dnc
it's hard to believe if you wrote this
as a novel
nobody would buy it it would be a
failure because it would be too
unbelievable
nobody would believe it's possible the
things that went on
and we're getting to the bottom of it
and it's got to be i mean you can never
allow this to happen to another
president this can never
ever happen to a president again sean
that was a disgrace
and an embarrassment to our country that
they were allowed to get away with this
and hopefully they won't get away with
it do you now feel
vindicated was there anything that the
attorney general's report and i know
you've called for
obviously the whole uh mueller memo to
be released
did anything surprise you and what about
the people that were collateral damage
in all of this
well people were hurt so badly uh so
badly
their lives have been ruined and over
you know over something that should have
never taken place
an investigation that should have never
happened there was no crime
as you know you're only allowed to do
this legally
if there's a crime there was no crime
they've all admitted it comey
who's a terrible guy comey and
mccabe and strzok and paige
the lover paige and all of these people
they've admitted in testimony that there
was no crime so they started an
investigation based on no crime
uh i will say this uh our new attorney
general bill barr
is a is a great gentleman and i've heard
about him for years he's a great
he's a great man had he been there
initially this all would
not have happened because uh what's
going on there is
just a disgrace to our country mr
president
but a lot of people were a lot of
innocent people were hurt very badly
and it's very very sad actually
for this to never happen again
what do you think the path is to getting
to that point in other words the checks
and balances that you believe need to be
put in place
so that a fisa court is in this case is
not
told hillary paid for russian lies
its own author doesn't stand by it but
yet it was used to obtain
four fisa warrants uh that gave a
backdoor to your campaign what do you
think needs to happen
to prevent this from ever happening
again what checks and balances and
what should be pursued or not pursued in
your opinion
well i'm going to leave that to our new
attorney general who's been so
incredible actually and that's based on
a lot of people
saying this is a very very special
person
and that's what you need in that
position that's a very important
position
you need so many different you need
genius you need
rationality you need so many different
levels of good
and i'm also going to leave it to
lindsey graham he's head of
judiciary and senate and uh
a very very good guy and a very smart
guy and
you know i i'm just going to let them do
whatever they want to do and
i i would imagine they don't like what
they see to put it mildly but you'd have
to ask them i think it's much more
appropriate i
purposely didn't want to involve myself
in this whole thing
uh i wanted to let other people do it
and i wish it didn't take so long
uh you know we're talking about really
longer
than if you think about it longer than
mueller it was
it was many months before that that
strzok and paige were talking about the
insurance policy right
an insurance policy just in case hillary
clinton lost
they wanted an insurance policy against
me and what we were playing out until
just recently was the insurance policy
they wanted to do a
subversion it was treason it was really
treason
if the republican party had done this to
the democrats
if we had done this to president obama
you'd have a hundred people in jail
right now who would be treason
it would be considered treason and
they'd be in jail for the rest of their
lives
but it worked out the other way and uh
you know it's just a really a horrible
situation
and an incredible outcome or certainly
very close to an outcome
and we'll have to see how it all started
but i'm going to leave that to other
people including the attorney general
and
and others to make that determination
but it's very very
important for our country to know
because
in 50 years from now in a hundred years
from now
if somebody tries the same thing they
have to know that the penalty will be
very very great if and when they get
caught before i get to the media
question
would you consider sir a pardon look at
general flynn for
example or you know
papadopoulos who's had to spend 12 days
in jail
is that something that you would
consider at some point
well as i told you many many people were
hurt incredibly hurt by
this whole scam it's just a scam but
it's much worse than that
it's the it's at a high it's at the
highest level
and the importance is so what it meant
to our country it's a very very
dark period and i think maybe we're
shedding a lot of light we're gonna
we're gonna come into a bright beautiful
sunny day
but when you mention general flynn he
was
you know he was a man who had a
incredible record in the military you
see what happened to him
uh the fbi said he wasn't lying as i
understand it and
uh and uh if the mueller group said he
was lying and
you know what he's gone through and what
so many others have gone through i could
name
names that would just go on for the
entire your entire show it's a
very very sad thing i don't want to talk
about pardons now but i can say it's
it's it's so sad on so many levels
let me ask you uh i believe you probably
have forever
branded fake news fake news and i i
i'm not sure if some of these companies
will ever recover
you know i talked earlier in my
monologue about well i don't really
recall them
ever talking about record
accomplishments record low unemployment
african americans hispanic americans
asian americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment
i mean some really amazing numbers and
but
i see every second minute hour of every
day
there are attacks i'm just going to play
you a small snippet i'm only picking one
network in this case cnn
and just a small snippet of some of the
coverage and
speculation and and things that have
been said about you and want to get your
reaction
russian operatives claim to have
compromising personal
and financial information about mr trump
we are looking at the possibility that
the president of the united states
and those around him during an election
campaign
colluded with a hostile foreign power to
undermine
the basis of our democracy this is
evidence of willingness
to commit collusion it does look like
collusion it does look like he's
listening to putin
more than he is american intelligence so
this picture
that the president is so desperate to
avoid this picture of collusion
uh begins to fill in the president sees
the walls closing in and is lashing out
he's desperate he's obviously flailing
around
because he feels the walls closing in mr
president
i can play an hour's worth of coverage
of that for
two years that's gone on what is
your answer what is your reaction to the
media i know you've been very critical
fake news well as many people have said
and fortunately we've had some
incredible people
uh that really were fair and you know
when you mentioned rush
or mark mark levin or steve ducey and
ainsley in the morning and brian
and laura jesse janine i hope janine's
back soon
she's back so many people i mean i i
just i don't want to
keep going because i'm going to leave
out so many but i could i could again go
so long but so many great people have
been
uh you know they they get it nobody has
been tougher
nobody on russia than me
and everybody said my enemies say that
when they're reasonable
enemies when they're fair you look at
the pipeline exposing that going into
germany you look at
oil with the number one i mean it's it's
what we've done
with energy and oil and gas and that's
all competition from
for russia you look at the ukraine you
look at so many different levels you
look at our military
look at the fact that we would have been
powered by
wind which wouldn't have worked by the
way because it only blows sometimes and
lots of problems come about
but we are stronger now as a country
than we've ever been
we're doing better financially than
we've ever done our markets are hitting
records all the time i have many many
records
of the highest stock market people's
401ks are doing better than they've ever
done by far
it's up almost 50 percent from the time
i'm
elected president and other countries
are
way down you look at china as an example
we're negotiating a deal with china
we're going to make a very good deal
with china
china is way down we're way up but
nobody has been tougher
to russia or on russia than donald trump
president trump nobody even close
and yet with all of that we want to have
a great relationship with russia
we want to have a great relationship
with china
all of these things are smart to do
we'll do great with it
but nobody has been tougher and when i
watched all of this nonsense it was
fake news just terrible fake news the
good news is based on polls and based on
other things based on
where we stand now with the public sean
uh the people never bought it they get
what's happening our country's doing
fantastically well
more regulations cut than any other
president and that's only in two years
nobody's come even close the big tax
cuts
so many things we're going to do
incredible health care that the
democrats frankly wouldn't even know how
to do
we're going to become the party of
health care the party of really good
health care
we've done so much and we have so much
planned
so what i had to listen to cnn which is
so
uh so fake so horribly fake
and i would just i wouldn't listen often
believe me i wouldn't want to listen
often
but whenever i did or whenever i saw it
i've never seen anything like they and
msnbc the same thing
the good news is i heard their ratings
last night both of them were
they dropped off the the folder they
dropped
to a level that nobody could believe
because now that they see the
mueller report where you look at their
finding i mean the finding was very very
strong no collusion no obstruction
no russia no nothing and
it's great and i noticed your record you
had virtually
record ratings last night so that's
because you have credibility so i want
to thank fox i want to thank
some of those people i just named but
also many others they've been so
fantastic to me and
and really to our country and i really
do they're really amazing people great
people
and it wasn't so easy for them mr
president you you know
one thing i do point out often and i i
honestly don't see it elsewhere in the
media
you did keep your promise on your tax
cuts you did set records ending
bureaucratic regulation uh judges
uh energy independence uh trade deals
uh being tough on iran jerusalem is now
the capital
all those things i want to ask you about
especially in a minute about immigration
and healthcare but
i want to just first run down some names
and get your thoughts james comey
tonight in an interview
suggested well maybe he was fired for
obstruction but i just played a tape
of him saying that he could be fired
anytime for any reason or no reason
which con so your thoughts on james
comey
well he's right about that for any
reason if you look at article 2 for any
reason
but despite that that was an incorrect
statement and when you say what i said
there was nothing said wrong there but
they didn't play the whole
interview when they play the whole thing
you see it exactly i mean the fact is
it would only get worse and i said this
it would only get worse if i fired him i
knew that it was going to get worse
not better i'm not going to fire him and
everything goes away
it would be a bigger deal if i fired him
and i knew that so it was a negative
not a positive and everybody knew that
but nbc
didn't want to play it that way they
wanted to play it a different way
and when you talk about people that are
dishonest and when you talk about
bad fake news nbc where we had the
apprentice for so many years as one of
their
most successful shows nbc is as bad as
cnn i can tell you that
let me ask you adam schiff is saying
there's still collusion by the way i i
think one of the funniest tapes i've
played on the show
ever is the hoax then you have a russian
talking about compromising material on a
naked trump
which is again talked about and he
thinks it's shown to putin and he's
literally colluding to get information
so that he can
impact our electoral system but he's
still to this day
now prior to the mueller conclusion that
there was no collusion
none and it was quoted in the attorney
general's report
um we we had a nine-month fbi
investigation they said no collusion
uh lisa page and peter strzok said no
collusion uh the senate
uh committee said no collusion the house
committee said no collusion
that's all before two years of mueller
um
but yet this guy is still pushing this
conspiracy theory
thoughts on adam schiff well schiff is a
bad guy because he knew he was lying i
mean
he's not a dummy and he knew he was
lying and for a year and a half he'd go
on and just lie
and lie and leak and call up cnn and
others
and just you know i watch him so
sanctimonious
and gets on and says oh well we want to
talk about russia
he knew it was a lie and he'd get into
the back room with his friends in the
democrat
party and they would laugh like hell
at what they were doing it's a disgrace
and he knew it was a lie
and therefore in one way you could say
it's a crime what he did
because he was giving i mean horrible
making horrible statements
that he knew were false and frankly you
know i heard they should force them off
the committee or
off the committee chair he should be
forced out of office he is a disgrace to
our country
and you have plenty of others but he
would go on night after
night talking about a collusion the
collusion delusion
and uh i will tell you this about russia
if they had anything on me it would have
come out a long time ago probably a long
time before i ran
because they would have been better off
much better off and i hope we're going
to
really get along well with them but they
would have been a lot better off with
hillary clinton as president
in terms of energy in terms of oil and
gas look at what we're doing with the
energy it's incredible in our country
but that's the first time in 75 years
competition for russia
hillary wouldn't have let you drill
there'd be no oil there'd be no gas
there'd be no anything to compete russia
if they
were at all for me and by the way if you
look at all of the things
they were sort of for and against both
not just one way
but you look at all of the the different
things
russia would much rather have hillary
than donald trump i can tell you that
right now
you after the election i remember and i
was a little surprised because i know
that a lot of the the
crowds and you had a lot of big crowds
with chanted locker up on hillary
and after the election you said you know
what let's move on
um do you feel that way today
no not really i did feel that way very
much the
the night i won they were all screaming
lock her up lock her up look she
lost 33 they deleted 33 000
emails and they were bleach bit
that's a big deal and it's a very
expensive process and
almost nobody does it because it's so
expensive but
that's the way you really get rid of it
so she deleted
33 000 emails can you imagine if i did
that
supposing i did that i gave millions of
pages
to these people that
were 1.5 million case was
involved with the clinton foundation in
another case weissman you know all about
weissman
and many others we gave millions of
pages they found
nothing if they would have found one bad
sentence out of millions of pages
believe me it would have been front and
center it would have been front and
center but it's true when i on november
8
16 one of the great nights uh
that a lot of people have because they
came from the hills and the mountains
they came from
the valleys they came from everywhere
sean and it was an incredible evening
and
you know they've been rewarded because
our job numbers our unemployment numbers
all of the numbers that
they really wanted are the best we've
ever had but i
i will say this uh i said you know
let's get back on let's not think about
the past let's think about
the future but now i think thinking
about the past is just okay because we
can never
let this happen again in our country or
to another president i'm not talking
about me
i'm talking into the future we can never
allow
this treasonous these treasonous acts
to happen to another president this was
an attempted takeover
of our government of our country an
illegal
takeover and if it were the other way
around
where i was doing it to president obama
or a democrat it would be
virtually the maximum sentence that you
can find no matter where you look
in whatever legal book let me ask you
now
i was very critical of the team that
robert mueller put together you
mentioned andrew weissman i've gone
through his record
was at hillary clinton's victory party
only democratic donors no republicans at
all no republican donors
and also jeannie ray who worked for the
clinton foundation as a lawyer
was appointed how do you feel about
mueller today
and were you surprised at all
considering the team that he
picked in this particular case that
seemed pretty
partisan democrat and i thought it was
extraordinarily
unfair to pick that bias the team
yeah it didn't seem to be biased it was
biased i mean it was
a tremendously anti-trump it was never
trumpers
and it was anti-trump i think in every
single instance
i know that andrew weissman was at her i
guess you'd call it the wake
which was the big evening on november
8th he was there
to celebrate you know to celebrate a
victory and he was there and
not a happy camper but these were people
that contributed most of them
contributed to her campaign
i mean it was shocking to see it so you
know i wasn't exactly sure i know
one thing i had nothing to do with
russia but i wasn't exactly when i
looked at the
team that was assembled i wasn't exactly
sure what they would you know maybe
they'd take a sentence from here and a
sentence from there i had no idea
i know one thing i was the most innocent
human being and they all said it even
comey said he found no wrongdoing you
know when
in one of the few times he didn't like
because he lied in front of congress
brennan
lied many of these people lied to
congress and nothing happened
and yet with flynn where they didn't
even know if he lied based
what the reports are and others look
what happened to them on the other side
but these people there were so many lies
and lies before
congress which is just about the
ultimate
sworn testimony where comey told so much
and he leaked he leaked
classified information well if somebody
on our team leaked
classified information it would be years
in jail
so nobody can understand what went on
nobody really understands one other
thing when
the report came out why didn't they look
at all of these acts
on the other side why was it they only
looked at our people and now all of that
being said the end result it took a long
time almost two years
but the end result is no collusion and
no obstruction
but it took a long time to get there mr
president you have the ability to
release the fisa applications there was
the original application three
subsequent
uh renewal applications we are told
andrew mccabe said
no dossier no fisa warrant that was a
back door to your campaign before the
election
uh the dossier also was leaked to the
washington post parts of it and isikoff
and david corn
to the american people and of course
never verified
do you have plans to release those fisa
applications
gang of eight information the 302s of
bruce ohr and others and
the five buckets that john solomon's and
sarah carter as they call
i do i have plans to declassify and
release
i have plans to absolutely release but
i have some very talented people working
for me lawyers
and they really didn't want me to do it
early on devin nunes by the way
and meadows and and you look at jim
jordan and so many of the people that
that were
they worked so hard and a lot of people
wanted me to do it a long time ago i'm
glad i didn't do it we got a great
result without having to do it but we
will
one of the reasons that my lawyers
didn't want me to do it is they said if
i do it
they'll call it a form of obstruction so
they'll say oh you release these
documents so
we would make all of this information
transparent you know in politics you
always hear transparency
would make it transparent and then
they'd call it obstruction
knowing the people we're dealing with so
frankly
i thought it would be better if we held
it to the end no but at the right time
we will be absolutely releasing and i
did the right thing by not doing it so
far
but you understand they would call it
something that it wouldn't be it's the
only time you'd be transparent
where they'd say bad things about
transparency
mr president due to testimony thanks to
uh georgia
uh republican collins we now have
testimony one thing that shocked me a
little bit
last week was the testimony of struck
and page where both of them
suggesting that the fix was in on
hillary
and because it was being every decision
was being run through the ag's office
that means loretta lynch
who also met in a tarmac with with bill
clinton
uh which brings us to a higher level
than maybe we once thought
um any reaction to that with loretta
lynch
apparently according to strzok and page
running the show
making the decisions for the fbi at the
time and remember the
the interaction between comey and
loretta lynch when he said it's an
investigation she said no it's a matter
well first of all doug collins is
fantastic the job he's doing he's been
incredible i wish he were chairman
but he's not but we're not off by much i
think we'll retake the house
because they see what we've done and
they see the confusion and everything
there all they want to do is
investigate and now the investigation is
turning out to be
something that's not very good and nancy
pelosi is smart she's
right in what she's saying because to be
honest with you
especially now after this great result
because i didn't know you know you
you just can't when you see the people
that we're talking about you just don't
know that
you're going to get a no collusion
answer a strong no collusion answer
but i will say i want to thank doug
collins i'll also say that you start
taking a look at what happened on the
tarmac
a lot of people say a lot of bad things
happened on the tarmac between
loretta lynch and bill i've had a lot of
planes for a long time i've never
stopped a plane on the tarmac to let
somebody on the plane
and then they went and they talked about
golf and their grandchildren for 40
minutes
it doesn't work that way what did they
talk about
and then she was exonerated she was
given one of the great free passes of
all time
and i guess bill clinton said he was
there to play golf but
i know the i know the area very well
arizona
it's a little warm at that time of the
year for golf okay and
people a lot of people it's a great
state i love it but you're not playing a
lot of golf right there
at that time so you have to find out
what happened in the back of that plane
that so many things took place after
that
incident that meeting between the
attorney general lynch
and bill clinton a lot of bad things
happened right after that
you have to find out so there's so many
different things and it's important for
our country that
those things be determined and found out
last question about people none of
if you don't mind i want to ask you
about substantive issues uh a couple of
big
things happen on immigration and
healthcare this week the last two we
know
that clapper light under oath i believe
the statute of limitations though has
passed
in the case of brennan um we know that
there was surveillance unmasking and
leaking raw intelligence
an increase of 350 percent of unmasking
uh samantha powers who is working for
the u.n
asking for 300 cases on mass she denies
it
but in that particular case of brennan
and
and clapper um and brennan in particular
multiple times accused you of treason
yeah your reaction well i think
brennan's a sick person i really do i
believe there's something wrong with him
and i watch for him to come out of the
cia and act that way
was so disrespectful to the country and
to the cia
and to the position he held and he was
not considered
good at what he did he was never a
respected guy
tough guy but not a respected guy but he
lied to congress
and the other night before the report
came out he predicted
horrible things so things he said were
horrible
and then today i guess he said something
i didn't see it but i heard he said well
i must have bad
sources or bad information i mean this
is a man who really is
either sick or there's some other
problem
but the way he spoke and as you know
clapper lied
and perhaps the statute of limitations
ran out on that one but it didn't run
out on comey
it didn't run out on brennan or strzok
or page or mccabe i mean mccabe
his wife got hundreds of thousands of
dollars
he was running the fbi and and running
all sorts of cases and his wife got
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
essentially clinton's from clinton's
closest friend
and then he rules so favorably i mean he
tries to say that he wasn't involved i
don't think too many people believe that
i don't believe
that but you know she got all those good
rulings
it's it's really a scandalous situation
and it's so it's so badly
that it reflects so horribly a guy like
orr with his wife
nelly orr and gps fusion she
wrote the report and then goes gives it
to her husband who's at the doj
and then he goes and brings it to the
fbi and she's getting paid for doing
it it's incredible the things that
happened
are incredible and very very bad for our
country well i hope you're right i think
we got to get to the bottom of it
because if we don't
and uh the media has been no help the
biggest
abuse of power scandal if i may move on
to a couple of issues
conservatives that when you had a 35-day
shutdown you were inviting nancy pelosi
chuck schumer to sit with you
uh you put daca on the table dreamers on
the table
uh you wanted to quickly they said they
wanted the
furloughed employees to to be paid
after 35 days you decided okay the
strategy is not working i was pretty
confident i think i've known you well
over 20 years now that you were just
changing strategies but we now know
that they couldn't override the veto and
that means how much money
now is available for the wall and what
what is the status the progress how many
more miles need to be built how many
have you repaired how many miles where
are we with all of us
we've repaired i mean literally uh
you know many many miles i could give
you numbers but many many miles
we're building many miles we're going to
have hundreds of miles
are already under construction or soon
to be under construction
billions of dollars will be necessary
it's absolutely vital if you look at
what's happening at the border it's
terrible with the human traffickers the
the drugs everything that's coming
across and it goes across the soft
points which are the points without the
wall
and we will have hundreds of miles built
fairly quickly billions of dollars we
took a billion dollars in today
and i'm building it much less
expensively than it was in the past
if you look at the past they were
talking about 25 to 30 billion dollars
i'm building it for a fraction of that
the wall is better
it's going up faster uh the army corps
of engineers is doing a great job
working with us and we have some real
professionals and
and the military has been incredible
putting up the barbed wire essentially
it's barbed wire it's actually
barbed wire plus but it's uh it's
incredible what they've done you've seen
it i mean
you know many many miles of wire
and if we didn't have it we would really
have a problem but we're
uh we're really capturing let's use the
word capturing we're capturing
uh people that are coming in illegally
we're not just releasing them in some
cases we're running out of room
in many cases now we're running out of
room the laws are so bad normally you
just bring them back but the laws don't
let you do that our laws that could be
easily changed by the democrats
but they are so bad and so corrupt
on immigration whether it's catch and
release or chain migration or
or any of the the various things that we
have to put up with it's terrible
so uh but we're doing fantastically
we're building in fact in uh
two weeks i'm going to a location
it's going to be in california believe
it or not they were begging us to build
in san diego begging us to build wall
and we're just in the process of
completing a major stretch of many miles
of wall and we're gonna have a news
conference there just to show people
the president it's really good stuff
it's better less expensive and goes up
faster but it's actually better
than what they were doing before so
we're gonna have it done
and uh we're in great shape but i got
great support from the republicans both
in congress
if you look at our congress men and
women and from the senate i really had
great support couple of them
people voted against but you know what
that's okay they had their reasons but
we had great support and you will be
able to use according to
the department of defense a significant
number of billions of dollars
uh because they couldn't overturn your
emergency declarations and
you know if you go to a lot of the
generals they will tell you this is a
national emergency this is
we need to defend our country your
people pouring in
i mean they are poor and now we're
capturing these people we're
we're getting them but you know we don't
do like other countries other countries
stand there with machine guns ready to
fire we can't do that and i wouldn't
want to do that
okay it's a very effective way of doing
it and i wouldn't want to do it we can't
do it
but we do if we have barriers if we have
the walls like we're building now
and and building a lot a lot of people
don't think we're building walls we're
building massive
many many many miles of walls right now
and uh we're gearing up to do many more
we'll have
hundreds of miles of walls built in the
very near built and renovated too a lot
of it
we were able to use the old carcass of a
wall we fixed it and we
uh for a smaller amount of money we were
able to build a you know wall that's
literally just as good as new
so we've done a lot of work on it a lot
of talent's been involved
and we've had really a tremendous help a
lot of people agree
i mean most people agree even the
democrats agree they don't say that they
go into a back room like i said before
about shift
they go back there and they laugh but
they go into the room and live everyone
knows you need the wall the democrats
almost every one of them voted for the
walls in the past
but now they don't because they don't
want to give us a victory but they're
hurting the country they're not hurting
me
they're hurting the country mr president
you've heard about the new green deal
you see the people that would like to
challenge you in 2020
proposals of as high as a 70 percent
top marginal tax rate for individuals 90
percent for corporations
a wealth tax uh the new green deal
says no oil no gas at all we're now
energy independent for the first time in
over 70 years and we are now a net
exporter of energy
because of lending bureaucracy and
regulations
and then it's everything's free
everything and on top of that then we're
going to get rid of the combustion
engine
and we're going to also get rid of
perhaps cows and airplanes and we're
going to be
build high-speed trains and just
medicare for all with
no other choices what is your reaction
as you
watch this new green deal in the
comments of
all these new candidates do you have any
reaction to it
well i don't want to speak badly about
the new green deal sean because frankly
i'm afraid that they'll stop using it
because i really do want to you know
campaign against it it's ridiculous all
right it's crazy
and it'll cost a hundred trillion
dollars nobody knows what that means
that means it's more money than you have
in the world and
it will be uh catastrophic it's not
gonna happen it's just talk
and of course they'll campaign on it
they'll say we're gonna give free
everything you're gonna end up
being venezuela if that's happening we
have a nice big problem with venezuela
you look at venezuela it was a wealthy
country not long ago and now it's one of
the poorest countries
will end up being the same thing the new
green deal is ridiculous but i don't
want to speak badly because i want them
to keep going forward with it
i really look forward to campaigning
it's just a little bit early
just like elizabeth warren i hit her too
hard
too early and now it looks like she's
finished i wish she would have been
in the race and frankly i would have
loved to have run against her but i
would say she's probably finished but
they have plenty left a new green deal
is going nowhere
let me ask you you many presidents had
promised
israel that they would move the capital
from tel aviv to jerusalem
you made the tough decision you got that
done i i've known the prime minister of
israel personally for well over 20 years
like i've known you for well over 20
years
um i i've always viewed prime minister
netanyahu yahoo as a
churchillian figure with moral clarity
um that few people had on the world
stage
standing alone often and i saw that you
i thought it was a very big announcement
about the golan heights being israel's
territory
um as you see the rise of anti-semitism
not
justing we we have members of congress
that have said horrible things
but in europe and elsewhere and
the dangers of this small country of
radical islam i just wanted to get your
reaction to
the importance of israel as our close
ally
well you don't have to go to other
countries when you see what's going on
in this country
yesterday i was very honored to do the
golan heights that was something that
was promised by
many many presidents over many many
years and i got it done
then you look at also jerusalem moving
the embassy to jerusalem
for years many presidents for many
decades
campaigned on it they were going to do
it then they never did it because
frankly
it was much tougher to do than people
would ever understand it was very tough
i understand why
they ultimately didn't do it they didn't
get it done but i got it done not only
did i get it done
i got the embassy built for a fraction a
tiny tiny fraction of the cost of what
it was supposed to cost
and now as you know the embassy is open
it's not just designated it's open in
jerusalem
so look i'm very proud of what we've
done for israel
i'm very proud of my relationship with
israel and what's going on with the
democrats
and with the jewish people and the
democrats and israel
is shocking to me you know i grew up in
a world where
people really and democrats they loved
israel
and now i'm looking at a world where
many democrats
seem to hate israel they seem to despise
israel and it's uh it's a tremendous
surprise to me that you know
what's going on with israel in the
democrat party is
absolutely horrific terrible
i meant to ask you earlier devin nunes
um who's been on the show many times and
i think has been
when he was the chairman of the house
intel committee he
wrote and warned everybody we have
watched russia over the years
a hostile regime hostile actor on the
world stage
um we know that barack obama caught on
that you know microphone saying you know
i'll have a lot more flexibility in my
next term and then
you know the case of ship being caught
on tape thinking polluting trying to get
information about you to impact our
electoral system but more importantly
we have known that they have impacted
other nations elections
nunes warned this country about how
hostile they are
on our elections um we need free fair
elections we do know that they
they tried attempted to influence
seemingly on both sides
how do we prevent them we have 250 000
i.t people working for our government
how do we not
have the the ability to stop this type
of hostility
coming from foreign powers hostile
regimes like russia
well first of all let me say that devin
nunes is someday going to be hailed as a
great american hero
they tried to destroy that man because
he spoke up for
for good and just in all of the things
that you have to speak up for
but most people don't have the courage
to do it he will be someday hailed as a
great american hero what he did
they tried to ruin him they tried to
destroy him
they tried to ruin his life and his
family and he just kept plugging like
there was nothing going on i mean it was
an amazing thing
as far as your other part of the
question
in september if you look supposedly the
fbi
told president obama all about
russia trying to get involved in some
form in the election
and he decided to do nothing about it
because he thought hillary clinton was
going to win
so he didn't want to do anything because
he thought that clinton was going to win
and he didn't want to upset the apple
cart but he knew about it
and the question is one of the many many
questions and
this is probably not as big as other
questions because you're talking about
major major treason and corrupt and all
of the things but
one of the questions is why didn't he do
something he knew about it
this wasn't up to me i wasn't president
when all of this was happening
why didn't president obama and the obama
administration
do something when they were informed
about russia and the election
mr president i only have about another
minute and i have thank you for so be
thank you for being so generous with
your time will
you make it a priority before the 2020
elections to make sure we have
election integrity and beef up our
defenses as a country
so no foreign entity can have any impact
is
and how important is that and the steps
that you're thinking about taking
well i think it's really important to
know that russia or anybody else had
no impact on votes and that's very
important for people to know and that's
been coming out as you know from every
agency and everybody that's done it
so whether they tried and how hard they
tried and president obama knew
the bottom line is they had zero impact
on the election of 2016.
and i'm very happy about that that is uh
that's what we're all about
we can't allow that to happen in any way
shape or form
but we are putting very strong
safeguards in we're having many
uh this sounds a little old-fashioned
but the best backup is a paper backup
not a computer backup and we have many
paper backups
just in case there is a problem
something which they didn't have before
but we are being very vigilant and
working very hard
and we have tremendous systems in place
john
10 second answer will you get now that
the justice department
on obamacare joining with the the court
decision
will we get that done it's we only have
10 seconds
we're going to do great with going along
with texas we're winning the case and
we're going to have great healthcare the
republican party
will be the party of great health care
you watch and pre-existing conditions
and choices all included we're going to
have pre-existing conditions absolutely
and we already got rid of the individual
mandate which was costing people a
fortune was terrible
mr president thank you so much for your
time tonight we appreciate you staying
so long and answering so many questions
we appreciate it
thank you very much